The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PRESENTER 1: The basic
concepts of reachability--
I'm talking about how
we can represent reach
sets in continuous spaces.
[INAUDIBLE] is going to
take it over and talk
about some applications
in robust motion planning.
And then Gerard is going to talk
about how we compute reach sets
and focus on these two,
on flow tubes and funnels.
So reachability is a
task of figuring out
what stage a dynamical
system can possibly reach
or be at at a certain time.
So for example, if we
have these two systems,
we have a finite state
machine on this reach system
and a continuous system.
And these are the
starting points.
And these are our axes.
We can move east or north here.
And we can move east or
north with these velocities.
[INAUDIBLE]
So after one second
or one time step,
we can be in either
of these two states.
Or we can be anywhere
in this area--
and after two seconds, after
three seconds, and so on.
OK?
So this is what
reachability does.
And the motivation for this--
one of the applications
for reachability
is for verification.
Verification is just the task
of making sure that we are never
going to reach any bad states.
So for instance, let's
say we have a microwave.
A bad state is the
microwave being open and on.
We want to make sure that these
bad states are never reachable.
So what we do is we
compute the reachable sets,
and we check for intersection
with the bad states
to see if the microwave
is on and open.
Or like over here, let's
say we have these obstacles.
Let's say we have a wall or
somewhere else over here.
We want to-- this is bad, right?
Because we can reach this state,
and it's the same as a wall.
Any questions so far?
Feel free to
interrupt me any time.
Another motivation
for reachability
is for robust motion
planning, which
[INAUDIBLE] talk more about.
And I have a video of this.
So what we can do
with reachability
is stuff like this.
So this is done using
flow tubes, which
is reach sets, reachability.
Gerard is going to
talk more this example.
So now before we talk more
about these cool examples, let's
just formalize concepts.
Let's define some things.
So let's go back to
the same system that we
had earlier, this state machine,
with a finite set of states, X;
a finite set of inputs,
U, which in this case
are east and north; and
a transition function.
And let's say this
is just [INAUDIBLE]
to keep things simple.
And we have a set of
initial states, X0,
which I didn't label as red.
So the reach set is defined
as the set of states
that we can possibly
be in at time t.
So more formally, there exists
a sequence of t control inputs
that will take us from
this initial state
to the corresponding reach set.
So let's say, for example,
you have bad state,
it's in the reach set at
time 3 because there exists
a sequence of three inputs.
In this case this is
one such sequence.
There is two more that will
take us from the initial state
to that.
OK?
And then the reachable set,
the reach set reachable set
is defined as the union of all
reach sets for time less than
or equal to t.
So the reachable set
of time 0 is just
the initial set of states.
And time 1, we have
the unit and so on.
So the reachable
set is what we use
to test for intersection
with bad states
because that's all the states
that we can possibly reach
from time 0 to time something.
OK?
Now as some of you may
have figured out by now,
there's a simple way
for finding segmenting
so we can compute reach sets.
So for example, let's say we
wanted the reach set of time 2.
One way-- the
easiest way we can do
this is to break this
up into time steps,
into single time steps.
So instead of computing
it straight for time 2,
let's first compute
it for time 1.
And now we can use
these two states
as the set of initial states and
compute the reach set for one
more time step.
And that gave us this
reachable-- the reach set.
OK?
Any questions?
OK, and the reason why these
works is because reach sets are
semi-groups.
And semi-groups
satisfy this equality.
So we can not just break it
up into single time sets.
We can break into any
two times, s and t.
OK, so all of this was
for finite state machines.
But for continuous
systems, things
get a little more complicated.
It's a lot of the
same concepts, but we
need to handle a
very important issue,
and that is how to
represent reach sets,
or just set, regions in
space for continuous systems.
Because in a finite
state machine,
we can just enumerate the list
of states in the reach set
or reachable set.
In a continuous system,
we need some other way.
We can't just say it's every
point for which there exists
a sequence of control
inputs, because there
can be infinitely many points.
So what we do, we have two
types of representations
that we like.
One is convex polytopes.
And that's just a generalization
of a convex polygon into n
space, into n dimensions.
And we have two basic
ways that we can represent
these complex polygons.
One is with these hull vertices,
like this, AB to F. [INAUDIBLE]
And then the convex polytope
is defined as the convex hull.
And in case someone doesn't
remember what a convex hull is,
let's say we have
just a list of points.
The convex hull, imagine
have a rubber band
and you are going to stretch
it out, and you let it go.
And what that's
going to do is this.
And the convex hull is just
the whole area inside this--
the rubber band.
OK?
And then another
way we can represent
convex polytope is with
a set of inequalities,
so for example, here
we have four lines.
Here's the equation
for each line.
So let's say this red
line, we want anything
below the red line.
This blue line, we want anything
to the right, so anything
greater than, and so on.
So this area is the intersection
of all these inequalities.
OK?
And each of these
representations
has an advantage over the other.
Vertices are good to test
for emptiness because when
our set of vertices is empty,
then our convex polytope
is going to be empty.
And this inequalities is very
useful for testing membership,
because for any
points, we can just
plug it in to every inequality.
And if it's true for
every inequality,
then it is in the whole group.
And convexity, I'll
just explain it briefly.
Convexity means that any two
points inside our region--
our region is not non-convex
is for the line connecting
these two points.
All the points in that line
are going to be in the region.
So here you can see
that this is convex.
And here, this red area
is outside the region,
so this other region
is non-convex.
And convexity is going to be
important for the algorithms
later on.
Gerard will talk
more about them.
OK?
Other than convex
polytopes, we can also
use ellipsoids to
represent reach sets.
So ellipsoids are just
the extension of ellipses
to n spaces, n dimensions.
And a convex polytope
is defined by this.
x is just all the points
inside the polytopes,
inside the ellipse.
v is the center.
And A just tells us about
this, how deform the ellipsis.
Any questions?
OK.
And one of the
reasons why we like
convex polytopes, why we
like ellipsis, ellipsoids,
is because of their enclosure
under linear operators.
So let's say we have
P that is convex
polytope or an ellipsoid.
Then, if we have a
matrix A, then A times
P will be defined that way.
It is still going to be a
convex polytope or an ellipsoid.
So if we have
something like this,
then this can maybe
getting formed,
but it's still going to be
convex, a convex polytope.
And the reason why
this is nice is that,
if we have a linear system
defined this way or this way,
and then if we start with a--
basically, if we started with
a convex set of states, then
our reach sets are always going
to be convex because we're just
multiplying by A.
And this is very nice
to represent-- this tells
us that our representation
is going to be good because we
can just use convex polytopes,
ellipsoids, and
stick with those.
And then just a technical--
OK, so even though the reach
sets are going to be convex,
the reachable set
might not be convex.
But it will always be a union of
convex polytopes or ellipsoids.
For example, let's say,
in the previous example,
we started here.
Then we need, after one
time set, we were here.
So these are the two things.
And then our reachable set
is the union of both of them.
This is clearly not convex.
But it is a union
of convex polytopes.
So we can represent
everything within it.
OK?
Any questions before I
move on to [INAUDIBLE]??
OK, thank you.
PRESENTER 2: OK, so now
that have understood
what reachability is and
how [INAUDIBLE] represents,
and before we dwell into
more theoretical aspects
of [INAUDIBLE].
Here are some cool
applications of reachability.
So there are many applications
of reachability to robots
are like complex systems
[INAUDIBLE] systems.
One of the applications that
has been talked about before
is the robust motion planning.
The early idea is to more
of a glider or an airplane
through lots of obstacles, even
in the presence of [INAUDIBLE]
these and [INAUDIBLE].
They're already
crashing into obstacles,
even when they are [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] applications
of reachability
to control complex systems like
by parallel working robots.
Here you can see that we are
controlling [INAUDIBLE] simple
soccer ball with something.
And more importantly,
reachability
is used for very fine safety
properties, for safety reasons,
like aircraft
collision avoidance.
So in those [INAUDIBLE]
we're going [INAUDIBLE],,
robust motion planning.
If you're interested in other
things, there are papers
and there are [INAUDIBLE].
So the goal of
motion planning is
to find a set of control inputs
that take you from the start
state to the goal state.
So in this example--
without colliding
with any of the obstacles.
So here, this is one
possible path from the start
state to the goal state.
So it just looks nice.
[INAUDIBLE] collective
things of the obstacles.
But if you get the
controls to this cart
and then give it
a real robot, you
might find it going--
doing something like this.
So this is because of the
path that you-- algorithm
that you use for planning this
path is-- that's not taking
into account any of
the uncertain areas
in the environment
or [INAUDIBLE]..
So there are different
kinds of uncertainties.
One of them is
environmental disturbances,
like there is wind here.
So that can move you over
off your planned path.
And there can be
modeling errors.
The model that you use to
represent your complex system
might just be an approximate.
So the real world is different.
And there are state uncertainty.
So the things that you used
for measuring your position
or velocity are also
approximate, so there
are uncertainties.
[INAUDIBLE] there can
be some randomness
in the initial conditions.
You are thinking of
starting the robot at 0,0,
but in practice,
you might actually
be starting at [INAUDIBLE]
0, [INAUDIBLE]..
So there is randomness
in initial conditions.
The goal of robust
motion planning
is to have some guarantees
with some confidence
that the system will reach the
goal set without getting on
with the obstacles
even in presence
of these uncertainties.
So this is the problem.
So let's look at some
of the solutions that
come up for solving
robust motion [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is a timeline.
So there are three
different systems.
And all of them
have a goal concept
where they use some
representation to represent
the reach sets, the
set of possible state
that the system be.
And then instead of searching
for a single trajectory
to a state, they search
for these representations
so that each final self-serviced
representations that
can go from the start
state to the goal state,
you won't hit any
of the obstacles.
So earlier Bradley
and Zhao and Frazzoli
came up with this concept
called the flow tubes.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
presenting makes sense.
And we will know all about the
[INAUDIBLE] of the [INAUDIBLE]..
So one approach that
we use is that we
have a set of initial states and
we have a set of goal states.
So flow tube is a combination
of all the possible paths that
will get you from any
point in the initial state
and point in goal state.
So this is kind of representing
all possible [INAUDIBLE]..
So and then you search
for these flow tubes
to be a path to get
your [INAUDIBLE]..
And [INAUDIBLE] constraints
so that you can also
reason about complex
systems and revise
spatial and temporal
coordinations like the walking
robot that you have seen before.
An [INAUDIBLE] about for using
funnels for motion planning.
So funnels is also a
similar concept to produce.
It's kind of like a [INAUDIBLE]
region around your path.
So that if you are
inside a funnel,
you're guaranteed to
be inside the funnel.
So in this picture, we're
going to [INAUDIBLE]
motion planning using funnels.
Again, there are references for
the other people's [INAUDIBLE]..
So instead, you'll be
using funnels [INAUDIBLE]
for every path, you
compute some region
around the path that
is a stable region.
And that's called a funnel.
[INAUDIBLE] your
funnels [INAUDIBLE],,
but for this part
of the lecture,
we are assuming we don't
have a hundred of funnels,
and that you'll see how to
use these funnels to do motion
planning.
So the previous example is here.
The [INAUDIBLE] funnel
[INAUDIBLE] flied by.
You see that it collides with
the trees and [INAUDIBLE]..
Then [INAUDIBLE]
like these funnels
are [INAUDIBLE] uncertainty
in the world that you have.
If [INAUDIBLE] everything with
uncertainties, [INAUDIBLE]
and then you compare
funnels for that.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: Can you please say
again definition of funnel?
PRESENTER 2: So it's kind of
something that [INAUDIBLE]
around [INAUDIBLE] around--
like you have a
[INAUDIBLE] around there.
So I think Gerard with
explain more about it.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
with funnels is
that you are inside the
funnel at the point.
When you [INAUDIBLE].
It's like [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you
have an [INAUDIBLE]..
So a funnel is basically--
it's kind of like a reach set
around a certain point too.
So the way that you do it
is you have some [INAUDIBLE]
trajectory.
And then at each node
point in that trajectory,
you compute some
kind of reachable
set at that node point.
And so you blow it up, and it
becomes some kind of ellipsoid.
And as long as you're
within that ellipsoid,
no matter what
disturbance you get,
you're going to go back
towards the nominal path.
And then so, when you join
all of those ellipsoids
over the trajectory, then you
get a certain kind of funnel.
And as long as you're
inside that funnel,
you're going to
stay on that funnel.
And you're going to
be on the path you
want to be at with some
disturbance in this
[INAUDIBLE].
So that the great
thing that there would
be an example of a funnel.
As long as you're in
the funnel, you're
going to stay in the
funnel, basically.
AUDIENCE: So is this
considered the control, or is
it only the dynamics?
PRESENTER 1: It's the
dynamics with the control.
So it's the flow tube system.
PRESENTER 2: Yeah,
so, you'll learn
more of those [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Let me
just quickly add.
So a funnel is type
of flow tube, right?
I mean, just different
people either use
the same terminology, use
different terminology.
Each of the applications
of flow tubes
has some invariant,
which is different.
And the particular
invariant on this one
is that if you are
you in the funnel
and you apply the LQR
component, [INAUDIBLE] then
you're guaranteed to
stay within that tube.
AUDIENCE: But I thought
the flow tube is actually
like getting smaller and smaller
in the funnel [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Not necessarily.
In general, a flow
tube is simply
a bundle of trajectories, which
capture some common features.
And then maybe that they
move to a limit of cycle,
and maybe they stabilize to a
point, and maybe that the move
to a goal, maybe that
they always maintain.
They're stable within a tube.
In a funnel they focus
particularly on stability
to disturbance and then
staying within the tube.
PRESENTER 2: OK, so
the [INAUDIBLE] example
is kind of useful to combine the
reachability motion planning.
So here is another
situation where
getting to the goal from
the start [INAUDIBLE]
and there are a couple of
sort of trees lined up.
But there is a path that goes
in between the [INAUDIBLE]..
This path looks kind
of risky because it's
pretty close to the two trees.
But there is another
path we can take
which travel around the trees.
And so if you don't need
the [INAUDIBLE] safe.
But maybe that's
[INAUDIBLE] too.
So that's why we do the
combined reachability
with motion planning.
So if you combine
that, you might
find that the first path,
if you compute a flow
tube for the first
path, [INAUDIBLE] it
does not hit any of the trees.
And it's indeed safe.
But it might happen
that the second path
is more susceptible to the
disturbances in [INAUDIBLE]..
So that's why [INAUDIBLE]
and also [INAUDIBLE]
combined motion planning.
Because what's
intuitive is not actual.
So far it's all about
[INAUDIBLE] planning.
So the [INAUDIBLE] everything
about the environment,
like where the obstacles are.
So that's not always true.
[INAUDIBLE]
So you don't always know all
the obstacles beforehand.
You can't [INAUDIBLE]
as you [INAUDIBLE]..
So one problem with
doing online planning,
there is that you can not do
any expensive computations
during runtime.
And all of these funnels can be
places that are very expensive.
[INAUDIBLE] solving an
optimization problem.
It takes a couple of
hours to finish them.
So you can not compute
funnels on the fly.
So the idea here is that you
compute the funnels offline
and do all possible funnels
from the start state
to the end state, and then use
this library to [INAUDIBLE]..
So you have the same [INAUDIBLE]
going from the start state
[INAUDIBLE] the goal
state in the archives.
So these are the set of
possible paths from start state
to goal state.
And then from each
possible trajectory,
you compute the funnel.
And the idea of
online planning is
to now find the sequence
of these funnels
that you can compose that
takes you from the start state
to end state without hitting
any of the obstacles.
So an important
component here is
finding a sequential composition
of funnels [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: So why plan--
you're doing a forward
search with funnels.
Why use funnels instead
of something like RIT?
PRESENTER 2: I actually
don't know what RITs are.
AUDIENCE: Can I
guess at the answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] thing.
AUDIENCE: Why use
funnels instead of RITs.
AUDIENCE: Well, or why
use funnels as opposed
to anything else.
AUDIENCE: Well,
I guess RITs, you
have like the classical
example, where
you want to go through a very--
well, if you want to go
through a very narrow region.
Well, first of all,
I guess RITs are
going to have a
hard time finding
the narrow region because
you'd need like a point
to go through that.
And then, RITs by
themselves don't really
account for errors,
maybe some extension.
But funnels, you can be sure
that you're always going
to stay inside the funnel.
So this if for [INAUDIBLE].
This is to make sure that we
don't crash into anything.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Do you
want to answer it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
what he just said, it's--
the point of the funnels is that
they provide a control policy.
The actual reference trajectory
that you have on the left
is the motion planning.
But with the funnels,
you get a control policy.
Because when you start
executing a motion plan
there's always going
to be a disturbance.
So you want a
control policy that
keeps you on that trajectory.
And there's all sorts
of control policies.
You could use simple
EID controllers.
They work in some cases.
But funnels provide
better guarantees
for the power plants.
PRESENTER 2: Yeah,
so the idea is
that you have trajectory
[INAUDIBLE] funnels
[INAUDIBLE].
You're using this
funnels compliance.
You compose them to find
your path to those presets
that you wanted to go in.
So you can not always
compose funnels.
Some [INAUDIBLE] positions that
are legal, and some of those
are not legal.
So [INAUDIBLE] example, a
time going from left to right.
So you have a situation
where there is a funnel.
You're trying to compose a
bigger funnel with a smaller
funnel.
And you have another
situation where
you're going to compose a
smaller funnel with a bigger
funnel.
So what if I would
have said, [INAUDIBLE]..
So which of these
combinations do you
think is a legal composition?
[INAUDIBLE]
Legal or illegal, I mean that
which of these [INAUDIBLE]
do not receive the [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: The
bottom [INAUDIBLE]..
PRESENTER 2: The bottom one is--
AUDIENCE: --is actually
marked because--
with the top one, if you're
at the very top [INAUDIBLE]..
PRESENTER 2: Yeah, that's true.
So the first one
is like illegal.
And the second one is
a legal composition.
So why is that?
So if you are
inside this funnel,
what this guarantees that you
will stay inside the funnel.
But it could happen that you
can go through the funnel
and make your outside
[INAUDIBLE] funnel.
And after this step,
you can go anywhere.
So you can [INAUDIBLE].
But if you're inside
the second case,
after you're through
the first part,
you're still set
at the second part
then we can decide [INAUDIBLE].
So now let's actually look
at those online planning
algorithms.
So this the case of your
planning [INAUDIBLE]..
First you can [INAUDIBLE]
with quantum's chronicles.
It makes our analysis easier.
So this is the algorithm that's
going through each of the steps
one-by-one.
So this is online planning.
You will always one
information beforehand.
[INAUDIBLE]
And you get to know
more about it as we go.
But you still have the initial
planned funnel sequence
that takes you from the
start state to goal state.
And then you check for any
new obstacles information
when you go out from the sensor.
So this is the region that
you can sense some obstacles.
And you also get the
current state of your robot.
This is also something
concern [INAUDIBLE]..
And you check if your
current funnel path
collides with any of the
obstacles you have seen so far.
And in this case,
the answer is no.
So then you apply the
control corresponding
to this funnel for this
[INAUDIBLE] location and time.
That take your one
[INAUDIBLE] problem.
Then you put Goto and then
do this again and again.
So [INAUDIBLE] update
from certain information.
And one obstacle is here.
You can differentiate
the other one.
When we check at
the Replan collides
with any of the obstacles--
in this case, yes.
So since it collides
with the obstacles,
you need to [INAUDIBLE] funnels.
So how do you delete funnels?
You have all this
library funnels.
So you go to each of
them, and then you
find one set of
funnels that has--
you find a set of
funnels that starts
with your current location and
[INAUDIBLE] of the obstacles.
So this was a point, first of
all, of a new funnel sequence.
And then, again,
you apply controls
corresponding to
the new sequence
and doing it two dimensional
[INAUDIBLE],, In the position,
if it collides,
and again collides,
so you redirect
[INAUDIBLE] apply
the control for that funnel.
And get a full solution.
And then it collides, so you
have to replan that part.
Then you're OK.
So now you reached the goal.
So those are the planning
plan using funnel libraries.
And questions about it?
AUDIENCE: Can you say
more about the connotation
of the funnel libraries?
So they generate a
set of funnels, which
covered the complete set space?
PRESENTER 2: Yeah,
so that's like--
there's every possible
[INAUDIBLE] end point.
And so then you can
make [INAUDIBLE]
or least, have it for
every initial [INAUDIBLE]
you can compose all
these [INAUDIBLE]..
So if you're doing it for
every initial [INAUDIBLE]..
So you might have a
funnel that exactly starts
at your initial position.
If there is a funnel that
already started somewhere,
where it goes through
the funnel-- goes
through your initial
funnel, you can use that.
So it's a truncation
of your funnel.
[INAUDIBLE]
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Why can't you use--
if it really is
an online problem
that you're not going
to run out of a funnel,
that you won't reach a dead
end, will it be adaptable enough
to make a U-turn at
all times, either
that there's come latency
that would perfectly time it.
And the robustness, that you'll
always be able to find a path,
even if we have guarantees
that you'll always
stay within a funnel.
PRESENTER 2: So are you
asking what the situation,
like the funnel, if you're
going [INAUDIBLE] backtrack?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just because
these obstacles come out
of nowhere, seemingly, that
you don't have a guaranteed
that the funnel is safe
through the entire duration
of our execution.
PRESENTER 2: Yeah, so
that's a valid point.
[INAUDIBLE] you can use the
adaptive [INAUDIBLE] backtrack
[INAUDIBLE] combined
with the [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Even if the robots
can't actually backtrack?
PRESENTER 2: If the
robots can what?
Come back, or--
AUDIENCE: I mean, I guess,
it's just like a UAB,
it couldn't do that.
I'm just saying, what guarantees
do you need to have about
the obstacles , since it's
an online setup, right?
PRESENTER 2: Maybe you'd
have some initial information
about some kind of obstacles.
You can find a
[INAUDIBLE] trajectory--
you can find a trajectory that
goes from the start sequence.
It's like [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm
just going to say.
If you're in some kind of
glider that can't necessarily--
like a quart of
stop, go backwards,
stuff like that,
depending on how funnels
you can plan backwards.
But if you're in some kind
of glider going straight
at a wall, there's no guarantee.
You're just screwed up.
I mean, even humans,
they make errors.
There's situations that humans
can't dynamically get out of.
So if your system
is dynamically not
going to be able to
make a sharp enough turn
or go straight into
something, no matter
how smart your
planning algorithm is,
no matter if you're like,
there's a wall right there.
Stop.
If you can't stop, and you
just go straight at it.
There's obviously
situations where
you can pretty much [INAUDIBLE]
algorithm [INAUDIBLE]..
You're just going to crash.
Hopefully you're in a situation
where you're not [INAUDIBLE]..
It's also based on how far
away your sets are received.
Your sensor can only
see 5 meters ahead,
and you're going 5 meters
per second, [INAUDIBLE]..
You're going to have
make perfect decisions.
But if your sensor has
perfect information
about the environment, then
what seems like the initial best
path may not actually be once
you know the full [INAUDIBLE]..
So it depends on the
[INAUDIBLE] sensors.
PRESENTER 2: Any
other questions?
OK, so finally I have some
demos showing simulations
of [INAUDIBLE].
Let's see how [INAUDIBLE].
So the [INAUDIBLE] applications.
So we have seen
how to use funnels
to do robust motion planning.
We also have the
offline planning
and come to do online planning
using a sequence funnels
and the funnel libraries.
I will talk more about computing
these funnels and flow tubes
and other kind of reach sets.
PRESENTER 3: Yeah,
so I'm going to talk
about how to actually
compute flow tubes
and funnels generally.
I'm going to give an example
of what each one is used for.
So we had the question before,
how are flow tubes and funnels
different?
Flow tubes are--
so easiest way is
they're both some kind of way
to guarantee that you're going
to-- the robustness guarantees.
So say you are here.
You want to be here.
They're both going to-- in
most planning algorithms,
you've got some kind of
path from here to here.
But say there's some
disturbance [INAUDIBLE]
down here or something.
You don't know if
you're going to be
able to reach there or not.
What a flow tube is
is it's some kind
of set of trajectories
that will basically
go from some initial
state, which are here,
to some goal states over here.
And basically, [INAUDIBLE] if
you're within this flow tube,
and you get pushed out on
a different trajectory,
you know how to get from
here to here anyway.
So you don't really
care if you're pushed,
as long as you're
still within here.
A funnel-- let's see.
So a funnel is, say you
compute some nominal trajectory
around here.
Using the system theory
and stability theory,
you know that, with
your control inputs,
you're going to stay at
each of these points.
And you're going to stay within
here within these circles.
So if you get
pushed out here, you
know you're going to be able
to get back onto your path
when you're going to
try to converge back
to your nominal path.
So you have some sort of funnel.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
How complete is the funnel?
It sort of related to
what Brian was saying.
PRESENTER 3: Completeness
as in like these edges are--
AUDIENCE: Well, if you have a
high dimensional state space,
does the funnel
cover it completely?
AUDIENCE: There's
a set of funnels.
PRESENTER 3: A set of funnels--
AUDIENCE: So the question wasn't
about if the individual funnel,
but in the particular
[INAUDIBLE]..
When he generates
a set of funnels,
does the set of funnels
completely cover the space?
PRESENTER 3: It depends
how much time you
want to put into it, generally.
If you only compute two funnels,
one of them goes over here
and one of them goes here,
then you're not you're
not going to be covered
in these states.
So it depends on how
much computation you
want to do offline previously.
So you get a set of
funnels that's here,
another one that's right
here, another one that's here.
And you have your big
library of funnels
that cover the whole space.
AUDIENCE: I think I
skimmed that paper.
And, yeah, I think it is
probabilistically [INAUDIBLE]..
PRESENTER 3: OK, yeah.
All right, yeah, but I
mean, as far as computing
where you're going to go, if
you compute that path of it,
you should be good.
But yes, you're right.
The probabilistically--
So here is what I explained.
Normally you have your
optimal trajectory.
But if you get
pushed off of it, you
may not get back
to the goal state.
But if you have a
set of trajectories
that go from some initial
states to your goal state,
and you stay within
that, you know
how to get to your goal
state, even if you get pushed.
Again, so some ways to
approximate flow tubes,
you can use some
kind of polytope,
which is as Gabriel
explained previously,
as long as it's a
convex polytope,
you can take that
cross-sectional area
and you can propagate it
down here for the tube.
You can also use ellipsoids or
rectangles as cross-sections.
And important point is
to know that they're
intercross-sectional
approximations.
So as you see here, you may--
this would be your
actually flow tube.
But your approximation
has to be an inter one,
because that guarantees that
you're with a flow tube.
But it means you may also miss
some of the outer trajectories
, which also, if you want
to compute a more thorough
approximation area you
get better flow tube
representation.
OK, so robust planning, you plan
a trajectory from here to here,
and that should be good.
But then you get disturbed.
You're still within
the trajectory,
so you're still good.
But some work done by
Professor Williams and Hoffman
shows that--
so what do you do when you're
actually outside of the flow?
Now what you can do
is temporal planning.
So we're using the
algorithm that we previously
learned in class.
You can take your goal state
and move the timeline back
to a different time.
So here, this flow
tube is, if you're here
in a certain amount of
time, can you get to here?
And if you get outside of it,
then you can't do that anymore.
But you can just
use our algorithm
and move back the goal time.
And then when you
move the goal time,
the whole funnel shifts
because now you're
going to be over here.
And you don't care about
getting here at this time.
You can here at this time now.
So then you move over.
And now where you,
you get back into it
because you're now inside
the flow tube again.
OK, so one example is a
humanoid footstep planning.
So this take a complex systems.
You have a bunch of different
parts of the system.
You have your center
of mass dynamics.
You have your leg
dynamics, foot dynamics.
So what you're trying to do
is plan your footsteps forward
and through time.
So you have your
original plan of where
you want your footsteps
to be for different parts.
So there's discrete things
that happen in the system,
as we've previously
seen in a lecture.
So one thing that can happen is
your left foot hits the ground,
and then your right
foot lifts off.
You're left foot lifts
off-- or your right foot
hits the ground, and then
your left foot lifts off.
So those are different
things that can happen.
So you have certain
temporal constraints
on the system that you
want to [INAUDIBLE] by.
And so as you
start planning, you
have flow tubes to get you
from one step to another step.
And that guarantees that you're
going to stay within those.
Even if you get
disturbed and get pushed,
your feet can still get
from one step to the other.
But then also, with
the thing that we
saw in the previous slide,
you can move the timeline
back and forth,
as long as you're
withing your temporal
constraints that you had.
So those are flow
tubes for the feet.
And that would
guarantee that your feet
go where they want to.
But you can decompose
the system to also
have flow tubes for
the center of mass.
So what the center
of mass does is
to be broken down into
separate flow tubes.
So does that make sense?
So this is the humanoid
footstep planning
that we saw previously.
And now you're
going to understand
how the feet are planned to
go to each of the blocks.
[INAUDIBLE] go video.
AUDIENCE: I have
a quick question.
You said that you
have a separate flow
tube for the center of mass.
But aren't they really
just the same flow tube,
like a high dimensional--
PRESENTER 3: Yes, but that's--
when you decompose this
and then you [INAUDIBLE] flow
tube rather than a full system
high dimensionality.
AUDIENCE: Is it hard
to recouple them?
How do you know that they're
consistent [INAUDIBLE]??
PRESENTER 3: Well,
it still adheres
to the dynamics of the system.
So you can couple how you
want, how you want it to move.
And you want to move
any basic constraints.
But eventually, as you said,
when you move your feet,
your center of mass
is going to move.
When you step forward,
you're center of mass
is going to move.
[INAUDIBLE] analysis of it.
AUDIENCE: Can I make
a comment about that?
Yeah, there's a technique called
feedback linearization that
can be used to decompose a
complex non-linear dynamics
assuming to the
set of linear ones.
And that allows you to
treat the center of mass
as a [INAUDIBLE] separately
from a control in the flow tube
computations and while
guaranteeing that [INAUDIBLE]..
PRESENTER 3: So
this is work done
by Professor Williams
experiment, which is actually
[INAUDIBLE].
This is the robot doing the
same kind of thing on Mars.
This is walking on stones
and planning its footsteps
through a pretty
complicated environment.
The stones are not
exactly in the path
where you would
normally want to walk.
But moving them around, as long
as you're within the flow tube,
you'll get to wherever
[INAUDIBLE] Awesome.
So that was how to compute
flow tubes and-- oh,
and another way you can
also compute flow tubes
is by learning.
So you can have some
kind of example,
move through trajectories
from one state to the other.
And you can estimate
a flow tube based
on where the trajectories
are, as long as the flow
tube encompasses all the
possible trajectories.
AUDIENCE: Is the
dynamics always linear?
Because I though
if your polytope,
and it would be like kind of,
is it a complex proposal when
you would use a
non-linear dynamic,
then you move a little bit.
Then you would move a little
bit, not being the convex shape
then.
PRESENTER 3: I mean, you can
plan non-linear systems too.
But as far as I'm
concerned, [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: So,
yeah, the polytopes
generally require
linearization with the system.
And there's a limit to the
validity of the-- the range
of the linearization.
And that's concluded in--
that's one of the
things that limits
the size of the polytopes.
AUDIENCE: But it is the case--
I mean, you've just
got to understand.
The thing that you do
for non-linear systems,
which is a piece-- if you're
making a piece-wise linear,
but you are--
you are linearizing
them at the w step.
And there's other
techniques that people
have developed with flow tubes
where you do require the input
system to be linear.
Right here it can be non-linear.
But... it's an approximation.
PRESENTER 3: OK, so
funnels, the goal
is basically to find a region
that guarantees you safety
on a bounded uncertainty.
So there are regions
of finite time variance
throughout all time during that
trajectory that you've defined.
And so in practice, there's a
trade-off between computation
time and guarantees.
So if your trajectory, if
you compute more nodes,
then you're going to be able
to fill in these little gaps
between each of the ellipsoid.
Whereas, if you
lessen them, it's
going to take less time
to compute each ellipsoid.
But it's also going to
not be as guaranteed.
And especially
important when planning
is that, if you're planning
in some kind of point cloud,
then some of the points may be
right here, where one ellipsoid
doesn't intersect the other.
And you might think that's a
safe path, when actually it's
not at all.
Yeah, so an example
is this little glider,
which is given in the
paper by Anirudha and Russ.
And so what you start doing
is you create your system,
your function.
And this is dependent
on your state, time,
and w, which is some kind
of bounded uncertainty.
And you choose the
bounded uncertainty,
which means that you choose
some kind of reasonable estimate
of how much can
happen to your system
that you didn't account for.
So you start it.
Your velocity can be
different from what you want.
Say your nominal velocity
is 10 meters per second.
You can have some
kind of drag, or you
can have some inconsistency
in your motors.
And so what you
expect is that there's
a plus or minus 0.5 meters
per second to your nominal.
So when you start
running your equations,
this is what you expect
your robot to do.
And then that can vary forward
and backwards depending
on what your actual was.
But then you add some kind of
wind on your system, which--
some kind of cross-sectional
wind, [INAUDIBLE]
direction, which we see there.
And so what that ends
up doing is pushing you
system away from where you
want it to actually be.
So now you have some kind
of velocity uncertainty.
And you also have wind that can
push you one way or the other.
So how do you deal with that?
Well, you start with
your nominal trajectory
that has a plane flying
perfectly straight.
There's no uncertainty.
Everything is deterministic.
And it acts like you want it to.
And then, so right
there the wind hits it.
So what do you do?
You have to have
some kind of control,
some kind of controller
to bring you back
to your nominal trajectory
and try to control you
around the system.
So a standard way to do that
is to have a cause function
and create your
optimal trajectory.
And this cause
function basically,
it kind of mirrors
a LQR controller.
And by solving a lot of
these equations, which
is a pretty standard process,
and to find out how to do that,
you get a controller that
tried to bring you back
to your nominal trajectory.
And so you get back.
You're happy.
But you don't have
any guarantees
just with the controller.
You don't have any guarantees
on how far you can get pushed.
on where you're going to go
and where your system
really can be pushed.
So when you compute
the funnel, what you do
is you choose a
Lyapunov function.
And I'll explain what
that is in the next slide.
And you try to minimize the
space around that function
that tried to bring it back.
So what this is is--
so you have some kind
of your initial state.
This would be the initial state.
And the whole region,
what you're trying to do
is minimize it around it.
So does that makes
sense why you do that?
So your trajectory
is basically going
to go anywhere around here.
And what you're trying to do
is find the region of space
that minimizes--
that encompasses
all of the places
that your system
is going to get to.
So that's easy to
do when you it out
and you know exactly where
your system's going to go.
It's easy to just shrink
your ball around it.
But you actually compute that.
No, forget it.
OK.
So when you have that for
each point in the trajectory,
you know that you're
going to stay within here,
because you're going
to have some kinds
of-- from your
nominal trajectory,
you're going to have different
places where your system can
go under the given conditions of
velocity and wind uncertainty.
You're going to go
anywhere withing that.
But as long as you know you're
still in that ellipsoid,
then you're going to stay
within those ellipsoids
as you go down the path.
Does it make sense?
Good.
So the reason they
use Lyapunov functions
is there's different ways
to measure stability.
And so I'll move
forward to this.
So there's different
ways to measure stability
in a non-linear system.
So in a linear system,
you're either unstable
or you're globally
exponentially stable.
So you're going to
converge back to your--
to whatever stability
equilibrium,
what you have at an
exponential rate.
But there is also, in
non-linear systems,
there's global
exponential stability.
There asymptotic stability.
And there's stability in
the sense of Lyapunov,
which is what we care about.
So the difference
between that is--
so say this is your nominal.
And globally
exponentially stable
means that no matter where you
start anywhere on the board,
you're going to be converging
back to this equilibrium
going at an exponential rate.
So that's the best
case scenario.
That's what you want.
Asymptotic stability
means that you're
going to be going from
somewhere on the board,
within a certain region, back
to this nominal trajectory.
But it doesn't have to
be an exponential rate.
So you can do something like
that, as long as eventually
you sort of
converging back to it.
And then there's stability
in the sense of Lyapunov,
which is-- so, say you're here.
Your system can be doing
anything, anything crazy,
as long as it stays within
some certain thing, which
in the 1D case we saw was the
little ball going around it.
So imagine there's like
a ball for each of these.
and this is where your
trajectory could possibly go.
As long as it stays within
that, you can say your system
is stable in the sense Lyapunov.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
So know this, does that--
AUDIENCE: I just have
a basic question.
So the Lyapunov function is
around a stable set point.
But the trajectory
has non-zero velocity.
So what is the point that
it's stabilizing around?
PRESENTER 3: You can stabilize
around a trajectory, which also
what the funnels do.
So we have your
little point here.
And this is your nominal
trick, some kind of state.
And you're wind can
knock you this way.
Your velocity difference can
knock you this way or this way.
But as long as you're
still within that,
You've got to
converge back to it.
And this is the value for
your Lyapunov function.
And these are the different
states you can have.
An important thing to
notice is the derivative
is a negative definite--
or negative semi-definite
in the case.
And that means that basically
all your trajectories,
no matter where you
go, they're going
to be going down this cone.
And eventually they're going
to to down to some value.
So does that make sense?
That's like pretty amazing
stuff and your system stuff.
Cool.
So once you know
that, it makes sense
to use Lyapunov
functions as candidates
for computing funnels.
So an ellipsoid is actually
defined by a quadratic Lyapunov
function, which is down here.
[INAUDIBLE] shown the
equation for an ellipsoid
is some V times S. So that was
the equation for an ellipsoid
that Gabriel showed previously.
The quadratic Lyapunov function
has the same structure,
where you have this being x to
[INAUDIBLE],, which is basically
the error of you state.
So it's some kind of
exact mean of the state
that you're actually in minus
x0, which is the nominal point
that you want to reach.
So this defines the
region around your--
the nominal point, which
would be somewhere in there.
And the ellipsoid is computed
by doing that minimization
that I showed you on
the previous slides.
And then you can figure
out the region inside of it
by solving that equation.
And if it's less than
1, I believe you inside.
And those are all
the red dots that
show that you're inside of it.
So that's used when
computing trajectories.
You solve for-- say that
you're inside a point cloud,
you know which points
you're going to get inside
of this ellipsoid.
So when you're planning,
you solve that equation
for each of the ellipsoids.
And you know if you're going
to hit something or not.
All right, so this is a
video that [? Ani ?] did.
And this is using
the funnel libraries
for collision avoidance.
This is showing for
just one funnel.
The glider dynamics were shown
in one of the previous slides.
They were pre-set by
the glider dynamics.
But [INAUDIBLE].
So you see right there
that there's objects,
and the glider plans
a path around them.
So the funnels-- this
is one possible one.
Right here, I'm pretty sure
they tell it where objects are,
even though they're
not actually there.
And it finds that funnel
being the one the guy wants.
And you see that
throughout the entire path,
the glider will stay
within the funnel.
And then when you're searching
with the online planning
algorithm that was
shown previously,
it goes through all
of these funnels
and eventually finds
the best safe one.
You won't always find a
safe one, as discussed.
In this case you did.
But it finds the best
one around the path.
So one way that it
finds the best one
is by finding all of-- so if
you're planning a point cloud,
you find all the points that
lie with the ellipsoids.
And the one with the
least amount of points
is probably going to
be the safest one.
So here's a bunch of
different obstacles.
And it safely maneuvers all.
And there's some pretty dynamic
movements, which is cool too.
So within that there is--
let's see.
I'm going to back to--
is there a way to get back to
the full screen [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 3: [INAUDIBLE]
So with the online
planning algorithm,
here's one of the
possible paths.
You have your point
cloud of trees.
And those were shown in the
previous, the little round
thing with the green
foxy tree-looking things.
Using a sensor model,
you get a point of that.
And as you're going,
you plan your path.
And the way that this
works is every five meters,
you plan a path.
And then as you're
flying through it,
you get new sensor information.
And you can replan your
path using the algorithm.
And that will guarantee
you that you're safe.
And when you're
flying, obviously you
don't see the funnels.
But right here you can
see there's probably
one funnel here and
then another funnel
that plans this way, another
funnel that goes to here,
and then another
one that goes there.
And that's a full path.
And there's also a cool one ,
because it shows that you go
through the tree.
And that's where
one of the funnels
is rather than going around.
It is possible that you start
computing a new funnel--
or you start searching
a new library here.
And you may not be able to
make it up the way in time,
given what speed
you're going at.
Does anyone have any questions?
And this is the online
planning algorithm
that we saw before written out.
And some of the
references, the paper
from the video that we just
saw, that's given here.
And that also go to the
example [INAUDIBLE]..
Frazzoli was one of
the original people
that computed a flow tube.
Hoffman and Williams did the
temporal planning for footsteps
and decoupled humanoid system.
And I did most of the stuff on
[INAUDIBLE] for that years ago.
Another important thing to
note that was a big thing
in my personal research was
that even though you may note be
able to compute-- or that you
may not find a funnel that
necessarily goes--
finds a safe path, you can
shift that funnel around.
You could even move it
slightly up and down,
as long as the first
ellipsoid is still within--
as long as your initial state is
still within better ellipsoid.
And that's easy to do
because you can just
give it a simple
transformation between one
state and the other.
And if you transform
this S matrix,
then that will transform
your entire funnel
and it will shift it around.
So you can find
your best funnel,
even though it
may hit something.
If it was slightly
shifted to the left,
you can just shift it
using that transformation.
So that's one of the
[INAUDIBLE] funnels too.
Does everyone understand
funnels and flow tubes now?
AUDIENCE: So I
have two questions.
So the side of that
funnel is computed
by the transform script.
Is that right?
PRESENTER 3: Yeah, if you want
to get it some ridiculous wind,
like 1,000 miles per
hour, then you're
going to get huge funnels.
But that's under some
kind of reasonable--
you know in this region
of the forest or something
there's only three mile per hour
winds or something like that.
Yeah, that's based a lot
on what your counts are.
AUDIENCE: So do you have any
algorithm that in your mind
that is not using
offline [INAUDIBLE]??
So this is like mostly
you do the offline
and the you do
the online search.
But if you were in a wild
environment, you do nothing.
Then do you have any
[INAUDIBLE] that isn't--
PRESENTER 3: I mean, there
are algorithms that will--
well, just the basic controller
will try to get you back
to nominal trajectory.
But there's nothing
that I know of at least
that will guarantee you
safety and will give you
an all-encompassing region
like flow tube or a funnel.
So flow tube you find there's
an infinite number of paths
that will get you
from here to here
with your system, basically
every little minute
change that you have.
And that obviously takes awhile
to compute and approximate.
And the funnels, it takes
awhile to compute the regions
where it can go.
So I don't know anything
that will online
compute this region.
But online you will be able
to compute some trajectory.
And then let your controller
will take your state error
and control it.
But it won't
guarantee [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: With the
funnels, how do you
compute your initial
set of states,
or the allowed
initial set of states?
You have these uncertainties,
like for the wind and velocity,
but what about the initial
state before those disturbances
happen?
You'd probably want more
than one initial state.
AUDIENCE: Here's and eraser.
PRESENTER 3: Yeah,
that'd be good.
Cool.
Thanks.
So with the funnels, so you have
your nominal trajectory again,
and then your
ellipsoids around it.
So when your system starts,
you have your initial state.
And your initial
state is just-- it's
going to be here at time t0.
But over the time
computed, you can
go over here, or anywhere
around here really,
depending on what happens.
AUDIENCE: But I
just me that you'd
want to apply the
funnel multiple times.
And you're initial state
may not be exactly the same.
So it should be possible
to use the same funnel even
though the initial state
is off by a little bit.
PRESENTER 3: Yeah, OK.
So say that you chose
this funnel first.
And eventually what actually
happens is you do this
and you get pushed around.
And then you end up here
instead of this funnel.
As long as your next
funnel that you plan--
so you can start a new funnel
at any point in this trajectory,
as long as the next
funnel is also--
as long as you have V
intersection between the point
and the next funnel.
And if you're
within this region,
and you plan the next
funnel, what do you do
is you plan the next funnel
with this being the original x0.
So as long as
that's you next x0,
and then this will take on
a new nominal trajectory.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm
just saying, asking
how you, like for the one all
the way on the left, that one,
yeah, how do you define how
big that initial region is?
PRESENTER 3: Oh, OK, so
that one, say, if you start,
say, not moving or something
and you got pushed?
Is that what you're asking for--
AUDIENCE: Well, I
mean, I understand
that you're using the
V for uncertainty,
and V and W. So that
essentially defines
how big those funnels are.
Do the also define how
big the first one is?
PRESENTER 3: Yes.
Yeah, the do.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PRESENTER 3: So what you're
doing, because what you want
to do is use the funnels
and have some funnel library
and be able to use those
throughout all time.
So you don't want--
so I guess what you're
asking, the first funnel,
you're going to start
at some initial state
0 with no velocity,
stuff like that.
And so you're not going
to have any uncertainty
on the first thing because
you know where you start,
the initial state.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm
just asking independent
of the wind and
stuff like that, you
might just be
starting at a point
other than what that
nominal point is.
So you may want to define
that initial funnel size
by some other
criteria besides wind.
Is there--
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
sensor how sure
you are about where
initial location is.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and then--
I mean, there's
sensor uncertainty.
But you just may happen
to be in the-- if you're
doing the glider
experiment 10 times,
you may not start it from
exactly the same position
every time.
PRESENTER 3: Yeah, you should--
your funnel, every time
you plan a new funnel,
you start at the
nominal trajectory
above that new funnel.
So you're not going
to have this funnel.
And you're never going to start
over here on the first one.
You're always going to
start at this point.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I though the
point of the funnel
was so that you can reuse
it without having to replan.
PRESENTER 3: Yeah, you can
move the funnels around.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you can move?
OK.
PRESENTER 3: Yeah,
yeah, that was-- so
every time you
start a new funnel,
you start at this
nominal trajectory.
But the next time you
use the same funnel,
you could be over here and
just shift the funnel down
to exactly the point.
So the initial state is never
going to be anywhere starting
at t0, it's not going
to be somewhere other
than the nominal trajectory.
But at t1 it could be over here.
And so you just shift
the whole funnel around.
And as long as your t0
starts at the new funnel,
and as long as t0 is within the
funnel above t-- last funnel,
then you just shift it around.
You can also turn it, as long as
you can multiply this and this.
AUDIENCE: It seems
like the shifting
and turning is a pretty complex
search problem in itself.
Is that a hard problem?
PRESENTER 3: No, that
was actually the--
[INAUDIBLE] I got
rid of the slide.
I might have gotten
rid of that slide.
I shouldn't because
that was the work
that I did for the [INAUDIBLE].
Let's see [INAUDIBLE].
But, yeah, there's a bunch
of different ways to do it.
I did a pretty not
very smart search,
where I just looked for the
funnels, the safest funnel
being the one with the least
number of points in the point
cloud within that entire funnel.
And then-- oh, man, I
did get rid of this.
But basically what I did
was find the safest funnel.
And if there still was a
collision within the safest
funnel, the I admit I had
a minimization problem
as you shifted back and forth.
And there was a
cost function that--
see if I can bring it up.
AUDIENCE: So you're
doing an optimization
of the online running of the--
PRESENTER 3: Yeah.
That was an input
that was implemented
in realtime simulation.
But that wasn't implemented
on the actual glider as of
[INAUDIBLE].
So let's see, all
right [INAUDIBLE]..
And you also want--
I also made is so you
minimize the amount that you
shift it to.
So you don't want to shift
it completely somewhere
else because it won't
be in your path.
And you'll end up doing
some dynamic [INAUDIBLE]..
Like, you'll be flying, and then
if you compute a funnel that's
here that's kind
of safe, but you
shift it all the
way down to here.
Then you're gliders going
to be doing something crazy.
And that may-- I guess
it would be [INAUDIBLE]..
But I minimized that for at
least [INAUDIBLE] shift it.
Does anybody have
other questions?
Yeah, so does anybody
have any questions on--
AUDIENCE: Can I ask one?
So you've given us models
of bounded uncertainty
in your dynamics.
So if you use
probabilistic models,
then your funnels start
looking like risk allocations.
Is there an
interpretation of one
in terms of the [INAUDIBLE]?
PRESENTER 3: I don't know.
No, but I'm sure if
you look it up, yeah.
I'm sure somebody's
been working on that.
I'm not really sure that fits--
I know I haven't done that.
AUDIENCE: Talk a little
bit about the interaction
between the flow tube selection
or the funnel selections
and the underlying [INAUDIBLE].
So let's say you have something
that's planning the reference
trajectory that's separate
from your flow tube
selection or your
funnel selection.
And then you have to
select the funnels and flow
tubes that allow you to follow
that trajectory the best
you can.
How do the interact if
you have a flow tube--
or don't have a safe flow tube
or funnel [INAUDIBLE] reference
trajectory?
PRESENTER 3: So you're asking
basically the difference
between planning with
a funnel laddering
and trajectory laddering.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, kind of
sort of-- well, because I
know the checkoff planner that
uses an incremental pathfinder,
so the planned path or
something like that.
And then you fit-- are
you fitting flow tuber
to the reference trajectory?
PRESENTER 3: Oh, you
do that off and on.
So you compute-- they're
called funnel libraries.
Or usually they're
trajectory libraries.
So ever computing a
trajectory in realtime
for a fast-moving dynamic
system is going to be expensive.
And then computing a
funnel on top of that
is going to be even
more expensive.
So what a lot of
people do is they
compute the library offline
for a trajectory and plan using
that.
But on this one, you
compute your trajectory,
compute the funnel around
that trajectory offline.
And then you search
through the funnel library.
You don't search
through trajectories
and then try to fit a
funnel around that one.
You just search through
the funnel storage.
PRESENTER 2: If you don't
have a very good library,
then you will not get
a very good trajectory.
PRESENTER 3: Also, a
cool thing about funnels
versus trajectories is
a lot of trajectories
will be discretized for
speed, so you have your nodes.
And so, say this is what your
trajectory does, and you have
node points here, and you're
trying to fly past a wall
or something.
If your wall goes
here, you're algorithm
is going to search these
points, and it's going to say,
OK, well, this is a safe path
because none of the node point
intersect with this wall.
So you fly [INAUDIBLE]
a little [INAUDIBLE]..
But a funnel, since you have
this region around it, you--
no, I did a bad job of
drawing that, but OK.
When we search the
algorithm and see
if it's less than
or greater than 1,
you're going to find all these
points being in that region
also.
I guess that depends on how
well you want to discretize it.
If your trajectory is
[INAUDIBLE] of really, really
small points, then you're not
going to run into that issue.
AUDIENCE: Seems like
you could-- like
when you're building a
normal RIT without funnels,
from concave points, if you
say, yeah, they're illegal,
it seem that if
you're automatically
adding on to that funnel
instead of generating
an entire trajectory and
then making a funnel,
you could save computational
time for [INAUDIBLE] things
like that.
Do you know if that's done?
PRESENTER 3: No, I don't.
I do know that, I
mean, computing,
you obviously want to
minimize computation time.
But it's not a critical thing
when computing, I guess,
funnels and flow tubes, because
you do that all offline.
And you want to--
I don't think it's
even close to the point
where you go to online
to compute a funnel.
It takes like six hours
to compute it, so--
depending on how many
dimensions your state has.
So, yeah, it's not
like you're flying
and you can compute
one of these things.
You'll crash like [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
[APPLAUSE]